round six of the London chess classic  the last stop on the Manchester the  players at a day to rest and recharge  their energies to make a big push going  into the second half of the event in the  all-american matchup world number two  fabiano caruana faced off against his  longtime rival Hikaru Nakamura in an  incredibly rich theoretical battle but  it was Bobby who proved to be much  better prepared as he completely  demolishes opponent's position the jump  into clear second place tournament  leader Wesley so took on former world  champion vasily topalov and after a  couple of incredible mistakes by his  opponent the grand chest tour leader  executed a vicious attack against the  White King to maintain his lead at the  top of the standings the best chess  players in the world around in the band  as the finish line is almost insights  round seven of the London chess classic  starts right now  [Music]